welcome back to the david pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show and it would seem as though
North Carolina has not learned their
lesson yet many of you should be aware
of HB 2 which was dubbed the bathroom
rule the bathroom law that was passed by
North Carolina there's some qualms over
whether or not they actually repealed it
and it the repeal was substantive but in
the midst of that conversation pad they
have forwarded HB 780 on yesterday and
this bill is an act to affirm that
section 6 of article 14 of the North
Carolina Constitution is the law of the
state that section defines marriage as
being between a man and a woman so this
law is a direct challenge to overfill
versus Hodges the Supreme Court decision
which made marriage equality the law of
the land North Carolina feels that it is
their duty to challenge what the Supreme
Court ruled in overfill versus Hodges
well luckily this has no chance of
actually passing because North Carolina
has a Democratic governor now Roy Cooper
but also everyone knows this federal law
trumps state law so because the Supreme
Court has ruled a year or two ago that
same-sex marriage is legal now across
the entire United States one state can't
decide that it's going to ban gay
marriage and have that be legal well I
mean somebody needs to tell this to the
state of North Carolina because the
Republicans the sponsors representative
Pittman forward and special they are the
sponsors of this bill and they believe
that they have a right according to the
law of North Carolina and even according
to the law of God they put this in the
legislation that you can pull it up on
your screen a couple of takeaways from
this legislation that's worth mentioning
here's the direct challenge on line 28
the General Assembly of the state of
North Carolina declares that over fell
versus Hodges decision of the United
States Supreme Court of 2 2015 is null
and void in the state of North Carolina
if you go to the next image you can see
the highlighted section oh actually I
want to read the entire thing where is
the ruling of the united states supreme
court not only exceeds the authority of
the court relative to the state of North
Carolina and in the second section they
continue but
also exceeds the authority of the court
relative to the decree of watch this
Almighty God that a man should leave his
father and his mother and hold fast to
his wife and they shall become one flesh
they quoted the scripture Genesis to 24
of the English standard version Pat what
the hell is going on in North Carolina
so they're not only violating the First
Amendment that guarantees separation of
church and state they're they're also
violating the 14th amendment yes allows
equal protection under the law and the
family argument Supremacy Clause and
there you go this is this is absurd if
and it's worth mentioning even though it
has no chance of passing Pat is absurd
because for every inch we make in the
realm of progress and justice and
equality there are people laying in wait
to undermine it this should let you know
where North Carolina would prefer to be
if it was not for the federal government
intervening on behalf of marriage
equality they would impose their own
version of Sharia law just a Christian
version of Sharia law and we'd like to
think that the marriage equality issue
is settled by now but with Neil Gorsuch
on the Supreme Court conservatives have
an advantage there now and if one more
liberal justice decides to resign or
they pass away the balance is going to
shift and they could just take a look at
that decision and if you think about
this if you think if let's say this
actually had a chance snowball's chance
in hell of getting signed by the
Democratic governor which it didn't but
this would set up clearly a challenge in
the court system which if it made it to
the Supreme Court and it was a
conservative court it could actually
undermine over for over turn over fell
versus Hodges but again like you stated
early on there's a Democratic governor
so this is going nowhere so long as Rory
Cooper as governor of the state